so we've made it through the first week
of the new year but what's coming up in
2022 from jobs to climate change to
politics we want to spend the next few
minutes talking about what this year
holds for africa now for one the
pandemic is still with us and the vast
majority of people in africa are yet to
be vaccinated now according to the
africa cdc less than 10 of people on the
continent have received the jab the good
news is that the same cdc
says severe lockdowns are no longer the
best way to contain covert 19.
so that's the pandemic but what else
will be on the horizon for africa this
year well we've invited lindsay chatel
onto the program
to talk more about that she is a
journalist with the new york times based
in south africa it's good to have you on
the program uh lindsay but actually
before we get away from the pandemic uh
we're hearing that there'll be no more
severe lockdowns but what does the cdc
suggest that the authorities do instead
hi christine thanks for having me i
think the africa ctc's
pronouncement that we shouldn't look at
severe lockdowns as means to curb the
pandemic has really shifted the focus to
vaccinations and what that is i think is
to sort of encourage more people to get
vaccinated encourage countries to push
push for vaccinations however december
31st was the target for the majority of
african countries to at least vaccinate
ten percent of their populations and
most missed that and i think that's an
indication of just the fact that you
know other countries might be in this
the
maybe in a later phase of the pandemic
but for so many african countries we're
still very much in the primary phase of
this pandemic because some such large
parts of our populations are still
particularly vulnerable and while there
has been some optimism around the
omicron variant being less severe we
can't relax just yet because the who and
the african cdc have warned continuously
that the longer we have populations that
remain unvaccinated the more there is
the threat of new variance spreading and
new variants developing and spreading
and so
you know
even the next phase 2022 of the pandemic
is very much still a very cautious point
for the arctic present
right i mean we've got to talk about the
economy right because economic recovery
from the pandemic is also a major theme
in africa this year
what can we expect on that front
well i think you know when we look at
the economy and so much of of the
continent we look at sort of before
pandemic and after pandemic and before
the pandemic there was a lot of optimism
around act for the africa continental
free trade agreement and this was meant
to finally open up the continent to get
rid of these archaic laws that made
trade between countries so difficult and
and suppressed trade between the surplus
trade on the continent but that was
before the pandemic and we know that the
pandemic has really suppressed growth on
the continent and there has been some
discussion of international assistance
there was a summit in paris last year
there was the africa turkey summit
towards the end of the year and we know
that the african union and the european
union will meet in brussels in february
but what we need to be paying attention
to is what these high-level promises
will translate to on the continent and
on the ground and i think we cannot talk
about the african economy without
looking at the informal sector there
have been various attempts at
formalizing that sector and really
taking advantage of it but the truth of
the matter is that the pandemic
suppressed the sector even further this
is where a lot of young africans find
work where they are able to push their
own businesses but with um
a lack of you know with importing from
china made so much more difficult by the
pandemic because that's where most
people got the inexpensive goods and
also just movement between countries
made even more difficult because we know
for example in south africa traders in
zimbabwe will come to buy here and then
go back that movement was again hampered
by the pandemic so when we're looking at
post-pandemic development it's very much
a sort of wait-and-see game
and what about politics lindsay i know
sudan is one to watch there are real
fears
of military rule there
what other developments will you be
watching
i think the horn of africa is an
interesting point at all times
particularly this year we see the um war
in ethiopia and what that would mean
particularly because there's a real
humanitarian crisis unfolding there
we're also looking at the sahel the
sahel region we know that and how local
politics will affect the region's
ability to respond to that
insurgency we know that mali for example
has had two crews within a year um after
the death of the chad's strongman idris
debbie that country that used to be um
that blade quite played quite a key role
in the g5 force they might have to pull
back to some extent too and so one
wonders then sort of in this vacuum what
that means for for the region's ability
to fight against an insurgency but we've
also got some big elections coming up
kenya is happening in august angola will
be having an election too so those are
just our key stories that we'll be
paying attention to
that's right well
i wondered lindsay um what highlights
are you personally looking forward to uh
this year 2022.
well i think what i'm hoping for and i
think with so many people around the
world are hoping for is that as the
world reopens that we do have an
increase and see more culture happening
um just before the pandemic africa was
really having a really collaborative
sense of culture in terms of fashion in
terms of music and then that just all
got tied down after the during the
pandemic and so i'm really hoping that
we get back to those kind of festivals
that saw these really international
lineups in places like malawi and
neswatini and fashion weeks will return
and because i think
that really helps to change the
narrative around africa that it's not
just about conflict it's not just about
strong men that the people on the ground
are doing interesting cultural things
and i hope once again that we'll see
that
right well i hope we'll see you at the
end of the year to catch up on some of
the things that would have happened
lindsay good to have you on the program
thank you
thanks for having me